I have been teaching three for more than
three years already
so I was given a charge to change the
course to make it even better than what
is actually done previously in previous
years and we actually made a lot of
adjustment during this few years with
many other professors in the physics
department so what we actually did is to
change the the textbook the textbook is
actually now much more theoretical
oriented so that we benefit from that
for the preparation for the other course
like ao4 which is actually the quantum
physics and and also the other course
which are related to waves and vibration
the benefit is the following so the
students who are have equipped it with
more mathematics background will also
find it much more interesting compared
to previous years because in the
previous years we are mainly focusing on
a very practical problem solving
reducing more theoretical orientated
content that can help us to
systematically understand sync
oscillator coupled oscillator infinite
number of coupled oscillator and two
were continuous and in phonetic cup of
the system in very very well-defined
theoretical framework and finally I
think what we really did is to introduce
a lot of demos made much more demos
actually than previous years so that it
goes with the lecture so that people can
actually look at those demos and
compared to our cellular calculations
and I think that is actually evolving as
a function of time and we were adding or
subtracting the demos which we think is
more useful or thus used for
the semester and not essentially what
you see now in the 2016 version